salve a tutti
l'argomento di cui parlerò nasce
dall'interesse per qualcosa che ha
fortemente influenzato l'infanzia della
nostra generazione
quando l'anno scorso e il nostro liceo
c'è stato chiesto di lavorare a una
tesina che avrebbe dovuto avere come
base dei temi scientifici che avrebbero
anche riguardato il progresso
eravamo molto indecisi su come avremmo
affrontato noi perché con me hanno
collaborato altri tre ragazzi del liceo
francese di roma riccardo valsecchi
costantino con figli e brando pignatelli
che mi hanno accompagnato quindi dopo
avere riflettuto a lungo insieme sul
tema che avremmo potuto scegliere per
trattare questa tesina abbiamo deciso di
distaccarsi alle tematiche che ci
sembravano troppo convenzionali e
discusse e che quindi non suscitava non
una grande grande interesse per
dirigerci quindi verso un tema che avevo
preso spunto da un periodo della nostra
vita durante il quale la nostra
concezione della realtà del mondo del
futuro
erano ancora molto influenzata e dettate
dall immaginazione abbiamo quindi deciso
di riattivare in noi la nostra fantasia
per quindi cercare di dare al futuro che
immaginiamo un volto inedito per questo
abbiamo scelto di studiare il mondo dei
supereroi perché in fondo chi è che nel
corso della sua infanzia non gli ha mai
ammirati oppure non ha mai letto un
fumetto o non ha mai sognato di essere
come loro
certo al primo impatto può sembrare che
questi non si concilino facilmente con
la scienza essendo essere prettamente
fittizi protagonisti di fumetti o dei
film ma partiamo dal presupposto che la
scienza sia spesso la utilità
dell'immaginazione per portare a
compimento preoccupazioni che sembravano
completamente al di fuori della portata
dell'essere umano
basta pensare all'esempio del rally che
cool e un fisico tedesco che
nell'intento di stabilire la struttura
molecolare del benzene trova la sua
risposta in un sogno quello che sognavo
l'immagine di un serpente che si morde
la coda è questo questa figura ciclica
in qualche modo lo portò a immaginare
che la struttura della molecola che lo
aveva tormentato per così tanto tempo
poteva essere quella esagonale mai
immaginata prima di allora ma che con le
aspetta 25 anni prima di rivelare al
mondo che per giungere a tale
conclusione gli era bastato
semplicemente fantasticare anziché
scervellati sì proprio forse per paura
di non essere preso sul serio
e questa è anche un po la nostra paura
no di una serie prese sul serio
comunque di non essere inerenti al
contesto di una tesina scolastica ma
questo non ci ha scoraggiati perché
convinti che facendo prova di
immaginazione da qualche parte sarebbe
pur sempre riusciti ad arrivare perché
la nostra terra quella di creare tra la
scienza alla finzione un ponte che ci
permettesse di scorgere un futuro
influenzato da con gli eroi che oggi
troviamo nei fumetti di spider man di
carta in america ma che un giorno
potrebbero addirittura entrare a far
parte della nostra vita quotidiana
se cerchiamo nel dizionario la parola
supereroe troviamo un essere fittizio
eroico che possiede naturalmente dei
superpoteri e che spesso nasconde la
propria identità dietro una maschera
bene questa definizione ci mostra come
il supereroe qualcosa di così
apparentemente distante e distaccata
dalla nostra realtà dal nostro
quotidiano possa apparire come un sogno
come qualcosa di raggiungibili o di
sovrumana
ma noi abbiamo voluto ispirarci a questo
sogno per cercare così di dare una
nostra definizione di quello che
potrebbe essere un uomo super più che un
supereroe è quest'uomo non avrebbe
bisogno di nascondersi dietro alla
maschera perché le sue super capacità
nei suoi superpoteri sarebbero
semplicemente dovute a un miglior
impiego di risorse già insite nel suo
essere umano come l'empatia la
sensibilità l'immaginazione la
creatività queste doti naturali secondo
noi se impiegate nel giusto modo
contribuirebbero ad alimentare ea
spingere nella giusta direzione da
sempre più raffinate competenze tecniche
e scientifiche degli scienziati per i
quali quindi diventerebbe naturale
impiegare le proprie scoperte per
migliorare la qualità della vita umana
il nostro eroe il nostro uomo super se
vogliamo guarderebbe al passato da una
prospettiva nuova e quindi capace di
rielaborare gli errori commessi in
passato non li ripeterebbe per concepire
quindi un futuro che sia diverso
completamente inedito noi vorremmo che i
risultati dello sviluppo tecnologico ci
venissero maggiormente incontro nella
nostra vita quotidiana supportandoci le
nostre difficoltà di esseri umani magari
fragili o limitati e che quindi ci
aiutino ad avvicinarci un po di più a
quegli esseri eroici che da piccoli
potevamo soltanto sognare o ammirare
attraverso i fumetti
l'uomo così pensato sarebbe quindi
secondo noi l'immagine speculare di un
progresso inteso nel suo duplice
significato sia quello tecnologico
scientifico tecnico ma anche quello
umano per questo motivo abbiamo deciso
di studiare quali potevano essere le
possibili connessioni
tra i super eroi tra l'arte del fumetto
e il mondo della scienza e devo dire che
all'inizio eravamo un po disorientati
neanche noi eravamo sicuri di quello che
stavamo facendo perché nonostante
passassimo giornate ore a sfogliare le
pagine che da dei fumetti che da piccoli
ci hanno divertito affascinato eravamo
sempre meno convinti che superpoteri e
scienza andassero in qualche modo
d'accordo ma è stato proprio nel bel
mezzo di queste ricerche che abbiamo
scoperto che nel minnesota
un docente dell'università insegna ai
suoi studenti i principi della fisica
proprio attraverso le storie dei
supereroi e sono a me lo vedete qui a
james canak ios e abbiamo letto il suo
libro la fisica dei supereroi e così
facendo si era accesa noi in qualche
modo l'ispirazione la motivazione perché
leggendo lo abbiamo capito che per dare
supererò in volto più concreto più
palpabile bastava focalizzarsi
superpotere cercare di decapitarlo ma
senza aver paura a lasciare un po di
spazio all'immaginazione
e così facendo abbiamo cercato appunto
di stabilire tra i supereroi alla
scienza e legami più strampalati in
particolare ci siamo divertiti a
realizzare un piccolo esperimento
ponendoci come obiettivo di realizzare
un materiale che si che si avvicinasse
in qualche modo alle capacità
straordinarie della terra di spiderman
scusate metto il video quindi il
materiale in questione lo vedete è un
fluido non newtoniano ovvero un fluido
che apparentemente liquido finché non si
applica una forza di deformazione e più
questa forza elevata più il fluido e
apparentemente solido resistente un fido
newtoniano invece come l'acqua la
conoscete bene a una viscosità che è
indipendente dalla forza che viene
applicata e quindi è in grado anche di
essere attraversata da oggetti molto
veloci mentre il martello che state
vedendo il video come vedete fa fatica a
raggiungere il fondo della ciotola
perché a contatto col fluido questo si
solidifica e quindi ne impedisce il
passaggio il fluido che avete visto è
stato creato a partire da una miscela di
acqua e amido di mais ma esistono nella
vita di tutti i giorni moltissimi esempi
di film impegnati ad esempio il ketchup
il dentifricio all asfalto quindi vedete
con un po di immaginazione quanto è
facile pensare un materiale che si possa
avvicinare le qualità straordinarie
della terra di spider man e la cosa
bella è che questo tipo di materiale
sarebbe anche
stimo utilizzi perché la tela di ragno è
da tempo al centro dell'attenzione di
moltissimi scienziati e ingegneri che
cercano di stabilirne di studiarne le
possibili applicazioni in campo medico e
scientifico
in particolare un'azienda canadese è
riuscita a sviluppare un metodo
interessante e funzionale che permette
di creare dei fili di ragnatele
artificiali si tratta praticamente di
inserire all'interno di molecole scusate
di cellule di mammiferi igieniche ed è
codificano le proteine di cui è composta
la tela di ragno in questo modo questi
mammiferi come ad esempio bovini o
criceti acquistano la capacità di
produrre la tela in grandi quantità e
questa fibra secondo noi potrebbe
rivelarsi una valida soluzione alla
creazione di tendini e legamenti
artificiali per esempio comunque di
protesi mediche molto resistenti ma
anche di cavi per paracadutismo per
esempio giubbotti antiproiettile
strutture comunque dall'esistenza molto
molto elevata ma per rimanere
sull'esempio di spider man il suo potere
più caratteristico più emblematico
sicuramente è quello di arrampicarsi
proprio con un ragno e per scoprire cosa
permette ai ragni di arrampicarsi in
quel modo
abbiamo studiato da più vicino le loro
zampe beh oddio noi in realtà abbiamo
utilizzato un gioco perché ragni e non
ci stanno molto simpatici ma il
principio rimane assolutamente lo stesso
insomma osservando quindi loro zampe al
microscopio scopriamo che sono cosparse
da minuscole di minuscole settore e
queste setole a loro volta si
suddividono in filamenti molto molto
sottili e ognuno di questi finalmente in
grado di entrare a strettissimo contatto
con gli atomi della superficie alla
quale del ragno si aggrappa è questa
prossimità fra gli atomi che dà luogo a
un'interazione chiamata forza di van
deer valley ed è proprio la forza di
mander valsa permettere a un ragno jacko
la spider man di arrampicarsi sui muri e
quindi di sorreggere il proprio peso e
muoversi senza difficoltà ma quindi è
facile immaginare che se un giorno
l'uomo disponesse di un materiale che
sia in grado di imitare le proprietà di
questo settore sarebbe in grado di
arrampicarsi e di imitare quindi molto
fedelmente il potere di spider man è in
realtà quel giorno non è poi così
lontano perché un team di ricercatori di
manchester è riuscito a sviluppare un
materiale sintetico chiamato che ex king
che sfrutta sempre la forza di van der
base delle setole
ma questa volta sintetiche per l'appunto
a devil a ogni tipo di superficie e come
vedete sono già stati sviluppati ai
primi sistemi robotici in grado di
sfruttare questa tecnologia per
arrampicarsi e quindi raggiungere luoghi
per esempio dove l'uomo correrebbe forse
troppi rischi oppure compiere manovre
pericolose come trasportare l'acqua
all'interno di un edificio in fiamme o i
materiali e nei punti più alti di un
cantiere ma noi vogliamo dare al nostro
uomo super un volto umano no senza
ridurlo a un marchingegno meccanico che
sostituisca completamente le
funzionalità e quindi non è da
escludersi che a breve questi materiali
sintetici possono costituire tutele
indumenti che l'uomo possa indossare
appunto per imitare quasi alla
perfezione il potere di spider man ma a
pensarci bene esiste già nei fumetti un
eroe molto amato e conosciuto che di cui
il potere di sé direttamente nella
corazza che indossa iron man fa uso di
uno scheletro per potenziare le proprie
capacità fisiche e quindi diventare un
supereroe
ebbene mi sostenete sono sistemi
robotici che permettono all'uomo di
recuperare certe funzionalità fisiche
per esempio la exor permette a chi non
ha più la facoltà di camminare di
riacquistarla e quindi un sistema come
un esoscheletro permette all'uomo di
compiere miracoli
e questo secondo noi sarebbe un valido
esempio di sostegno civile è reso
possibile da una parte grazie alla
scienza e dall'altra grazie al mito del
supereroe che fornisce l'ispirazione
necessaria per raggiungere l'obiettivo
apparentemente così remoto ma esistono
su scheletri che concettualmente molto
simili all'ex permettono non solo di
recuperare alcune funzioni fisiche ma
anche di potenziarle quindi
permetterebbero un uomo per esempio in
un'attività industriale o in un cantiere
di qom per azioni per le quali
servirebbero più di quattro braccia
anziché 2 e limiterebbero anche
notevolmente i rischi che non occorre in
questo tipo di attività
ma in fin dei conti insomma l'idea che
dietro tutto questo questo progetto e
che fornire secondo noi fuoriuscire
dagli schemi imposti senza aver paura di
adoperare la nostra fantasia e la nostra
creatività il nostro ingegno per dare al
futuro che immaginiamo in volto più
ambizioso più singolare sarebbe il primo
passo verso un mondo dove l'uomo si è in
grado di
vivere in totale simbiosi con il
progresso tecnologico così facendo
secondo noi si potrebbe addirittura
arrivare immaginare che un giorno quegli
eroi che si trovano nei fumetti di cui
abbiamo parlato potrebbero addirittura
arrivare a popolare il nostro mondo e
quindi assicurarsi una realtà che sia
più sicura e che comporta meno rischi e
più vantaggi per chi la vive grazie a
creazioni e comparabili a cui
paragonabili a quelle che troviamo nei
fumetti
l'uomo potrebbe addirittura raggiungere
i luoghi più esplorati e quindi
estendere la propria conoscenza
dell'universo come lo circonda e degli
esseri che lo popolano perché ognuno di
questi esseri che nei propri sogni
nasconde la forza la grandezza di un
supereroe
grazie vorrei invitare sul palco i
ragazzi che hanno partecipato con me a
questa desina a questo progetto insomma
costantino avanti ii brando vignatelli e
riccardo valsecchi e questo è il
progetto originale che era in francese
perché frequentiamo al liceo stato prima
un di roma grazie